sacrifice
is a part of any journey taking on these
great challenges
against great odds
that's what makes us human
for all mankind is an alternate history
of the space race when we come back into
season two it's
almost 10 years later it's 1983 both
sides
expand on their moon bases and the
competition between the two superpowers
has also gotten much more intense
we're coming into an alternate history
of the new 1980s
the social change is more rapid the
development of technology
goes much quicker no more gas stations
you get 60 miles on a single charge we
have electric cars we have cell phones
because the russians land on the moon
first nasa is not defunded and it pushes
us
further into technology in a competitive
way
this is jamestown actual enjoy the show
everyone
in space jamestown has expanded
drastically
there's up to 30 astronauts on the moon
at any given time
it's a really exciting leap forward in
season two
let me state as plainly as i can the
greatest threat the united states faces
is posed by the soviet union there's
rising tensions
between the superpowers the cold war
rather than
cooling off it's the exact opposite
it becomes about ownership of the moon
by militarizing the moon to try and
stake a claim
the president wants us to confront the
soviets on the moon
they're going to need weapons right we
see
the military presence and how that
affects life on the moon
we need to send a message to the soviets
but there's got to be another way
[Music]
recommend go to defcon 3.
season 2 is everything you loved about
season 1
taken a step further bringing the cold
war conflict to the moon
it's a big part of season two and it
will be quite a shock and surprise
follow emergency power protocols scream
the nuclear reactors
copy it's just an exquisitely
executed show about human beings in
extreme situations
once we do this thing
there's no going back
history has asked much of the americans
of our time
much more we must be prepared to give
you